[inaudible] [inaudible]
let's keep going through
the grammar of words.
This time we're going to focus on the
part of speech known as the pronouns.
Pronouns work. A lot like nouns.
They don't necessarily reference a
specific concept like a noun does,
but they can stand in for now,
relate back to a now and they often
share a lot of the same properties.
Just like with nouns,
we can expect that pronouns can
reference a specific number,
so we might have a distinction between
singular and plural or singular,
dual and plural.
This allows some languages to distinguish
between a singular you and a group of
you in the plural
pronouns also commonly show
person. I am the first person.
You are the second person he
she or it is the third person,
but notice that an English, we
have a second set for the plural.
We are the first person.
You all are the second person and they
are the third person plural in English.
The third person singular draws a
distinction between he, she and it,
but the third person plural, they doesn't
make this differentiation in Romanian.
On the other hand, gender is actually
reflected in the third person,
plural pronouns.
We have Yay for a group of
males or males and females,
mixed gender and yelly for a group
entirely composed of females or feminine
nouns. The final property we'll talk
about when dealing with pronouns is case.
This is easier in English because we
actually do distinguish case with our
pronouns. Unlike with our nouns,
think about the subject or nominated
case versus the accusative or object case
that I introduced when discussing nouns.
I say I when I'm the subject,
but me, when I'm the object.
Compare ICU too. You see me?
Both of these are first person singular
pronouns. In the first sentence,
it's in the nominative or subject case
I and the second it's in the object or
accusative case. Me
[inaudible]
just as with nouns,
we can lay all of these properties out
and we ended up with a declension of a
pronoun.
[inaudible].
You now have a taste of
the grammar of pronouns.
Please join me next time for
an overview of adjectives.
[inaudible].